[Music]
an American we're at least
cause there ain't no doubt I love this
land God Bless the USA
[Music]
thank you from the lakes of Minnesota
to the hills of Tennessee
across the plains of Texas
[Music]
I'm free today
because there ain't no doubt I love this
land God Bless the USA
[Music]
be an American where it is
[Applause]
[Music]
well thank you very much and
well thank you very much and I'm
thrilled to be back with the
hard-working God-fearing card-caring
Patriots of the NRA thank you very much
everybody
[Applause]
as a candidate in 2016 I promise you
that I would save your second amendment
from absolute obliteration that's where
it was going
and as your president that's exactly
what I did we saved our Second Amendment
and we're going to save it for a long
time to come it's under siege but we're
going to save it for a long time to come
forever as far as I'm concerned forever
and thank you very much
so I was proud to be the most pro-gun
pro-second Amendment president you've
ever had in the white house I think
that's been acknowledged and with your
support in 2024
I will be your loyal friend and fearless
Champion once again as the 47th
president of the United States
[Applause]
and we have to remember in 2016 we won
the first time and we did better the
second time got a lot more votes a lot
of bad things happened though didn't
they huh
a lot of bad things happen I want to
thank Wayne LaPierre and Charles cotton
for their leadership as well as all of
the people that work with them
the NRA members who make up this
incredible organization and
that's really a tremendous Force for
Freedom that's what it is and I'm very
proud to be here
thanks as well to Congressman Jim Jordan
and his incredible wife Polly
where is Jim he's around here someplace
where's the gym
and also with them uh
came along Isaac you know Isaac is a
wrestler four-time All-American if
anybody's into sports even a little bit
four-time all-americans good and Jim was
a great wrestler a lot of people don't
know that and his daughter his
daughter-in-law Brook and she's about to
have a baby I said when is the baby
coming she said it could be today or
tomorrow I said what are you doing here
but uh he's a spectacular Congressman
politician and person and so I just want
to thank Jim and the whole family and
Polly thank you very much for being here
and
somebody that I believe is going to be
and a friend of Jim is going to be your
next senator from the great state of
Indiana which I love so much Jim Banks
where's Jim Banks Jim Banks Jim
hi Jim
he's so popular now he's unopposed we
like it that way don't we
thank you very much Jim you're doing
fantastically well Indiana lieutenant
governor Suzanne Crouch thank you very
much thank you
thank you Suzanne where is Suzanne
Suzanne thank you very much
and also attorney general Todd Roquita
Todd where is Todd
leaves some place here I saw him it's a
big crowd Todd that's a big crowd thank
you very much great job dad doing a
great job
for seven years all of us here today
have been engaged in an epic struggle
against the corrupt forces in communist
maniacs and they're all over the place
that are absolutely trying to destroy
our country
they want to take away your guns while
throwing open the jailhouse doors and
releasing bloodthirsty criminals into
your communities
they want to abolish your borders and
impoverish your families while spending
your money on endless and very very
stupid Foreign Wars
they want to demonize Patriots and
persecute Christians while pushing the
transgender cult on your children
children
turn 25 and they say who did this to me
who did this to me how did you let this
happen
they want to weaponize and interfere
with our elections through the use of
the doj the FBI and local attorney
generals and district attorneys
that's happening to me but we're doing
very well thank you
it's actually called election
interference that's all they want to do
I'll tell you what if I weren't running
which isn't going to happen
or if I was doing badly in the polls and
we're not going to let that happen
either we're killing them in the polls
are you seeing the numbers
they wouldn't be doing anything
they'd be after somebody else they
wouldn't be talking but uh we're going
to show you some of the polls in a
little while you're going to be amazed
we really made a lot of progress over
the last month
we put it into high gear
like we did for four years when this
country had no problems
and then covid came in and we got it
back when you think about it it was
amazing and we actually left it with a
stock market that was higher than just
pre-covered coming in it was an amazing
job that we did we built it twice but
there was nothing like it I mean there
was nothing like it what we did in those
four years were
really Monumental rebuilt our military
largest tax cuts in history largest
regulation Cuts in history the creation
of space force that was a big deal
that was a big deal and so many other
things even right to dry out nobody
needs it great to try where you can use
this uh Advanced Medical Treatments that
won't be approved for five or six years
by the FDA but we got them to move a lot
faster I will tell you on everything but
won't be approved by the FDA for years
and we've saved thousands and thousands
of lives with right to try but we did a
lot we did a lot
2024 is the year that we will defeat
these Nation wrecking globalist marxists
rhinos and tyrants once and for all the
rhinos are in there many ways
in many ways the rhinos are worse
because you don't know where they're
coming from
it's a rhino we don't like
Democrats you know where they're coming
from and that's not a good place is it
if you put me back in the White House
their reign is over and America will be
a free Nation once again
[Applause]
and I promise you this with me at 1600
Pennsylvania Avenue no one will lay a
finger on your Firearms just as took
place for four years
When I was Your president I will uphold
those glorious words
shall not be infringed you know those
words I think you know those words you
know
every pledge I made to you as a
candidate in 2016 I fulfilled as your
president I appointed nearly 300 federal
judges to fill the bench with
pro-constitution Warriors who interpret
the law as written we have great judges
a lot of great justices almost 300 a
record I face down vile attacks from the
radical left to confirm three great
Supreme Court Justices you know who they
are Neil Gorsuch Brett Kavanaugh Amy
Cooney Barrett all outstanding people
they don't help me much I got to tell
you that they vote against me too much
but
one of those little things in life right
but they are outstanding people and
great Scholars brilliant and they've
done a very good job I always say except
for me they've done a very good job
standing before like show your tax
returns
that wasn't supposed to happen right
show your tax returns I thought that
wasn't
in Totem and you know what happened
nothing
they said this guy made a lot of money
standing before you at the NRA
leadership Forum in 2019 I revoked
America's signature from the globalist
United Nations arms trade treaty which
was a disaster
I never surrendered to the globalist
left and
I always put our term America First very
simple America first
I canceled Barack Hussein Obama's
corrupt use of Social Security data to
deny Americans their gun rights without
due process of law you know that very
well in this Auditorium
I fought Obama's unconstitutional effort
to ban 3D printed guns I stood up for
our Hunters Fishers and Sportsmen like
no other president has ever done before
opening up millions of Acres of federal
land and rolling back Obama's assaults
on Hunting Fishing trapping and on
ammunition itself
when the radical left Democrats tried to
use covet to shut down gun sales during
the China virus pandemic I proudly
designated gun and ammunition retailers
as critical infrastructure do you
remember that little things like that
it saved all of them a lot of them are
in the room with us today
my Administration also petitioned the
Supreme Court to overturn New York
City's
unconstitutional I mean so many
unconstitutional things are taking place
in these democrat-run cities but it was
an unconstitutional ban on transporting
handguns outside of the home and in a
landmark case last June the court
affirmed that the right to self-defense
does not end when you step outside the
front door of your house
and we did all of this and we did
we did oh and going to finish everything
that we started we finished a lot of it
already in the four years but we have
things to do and we have things to
finish and we're going to get that done
and we're going to have a big big
successful election coming up we're
going to take back that beautiful
gorgeous White House
hey one of my new term Iowa will stop
Joe Biden's war on lawful gun owners
it's a war it's a what they're doing is
is crazy so many things they're great
let's see no borders high taxes
everything they do you know I made a
speech recently and I used this term and
I didn't even know we were using it but
I used it every day is like April Fool's
Day
we want nobody
you've got to have borders we want no
walls no no you got to have walls
everything is like the opposite this is
April fools right we want high taxes no
no we want to keep our taxes low
we want no guns no no we want people to
be able to
protect themselves and also enjoy it as
entertainment and go out and hunt and do
the things that you want to do
it's almost like April fools everything
that they do is like
we want to have a weak military we want
our military to be woke
you know we built we rebuilt the entire
U.S Presbyterian we had planes that were
48 years old
we built brand new beautiful Jets we had
planes where the grandfathers were
flying the same plane as the grandson
but we rebuilt our entire military I
mean I hate to say this we gave 85
billion dollars of it to
the Taliban in Afghanistan
in probably the most embarrassing single
moment in the history of our country
which I believe led to Russia going in
they would have never done that with us
but I believe it led to that and led to
a lot of bad things that was the most
embarrassing period of time I think in
our nation's history not only that the
soldiers killed 13 killed many just
horribly horribly wounded hurt no arms
no legs faces were just
so badly hurt
and we left a lot of people there too
and then we gave up Bagram Air Base a
big Air Base one hour from where China
makes its nuclear weapons you should
have never given that up
and I call it a surrender we actually
surrendered we were in great shape you
know um
if you look back on that history you're
going to see something that was
interesting I dealt with Abdul Abdul was
the leader of the Taliban and I took a
lot of heat from all of those fake news
people back there
they said why do you call Abdul Abdul is
the leader of the Taliban they're the
ones that were fighting and fighting
hard
and I related to Jesse James I say well
Jesse James a great bank robber great
Outlaw they said why do you always rob
banks Jesse he said because that's where
the money is so when I dealt with Abdul
he's the one that was shooting our
young soldiers and others
with snipers and lots of other things
and I said Abdul you can't do that you
can't do that over the phone
and you do that you're gonna suffer like
nobody's ever suffered your whole
Community is going to be terrible will
hit you harder than anybody's ever been
hit
he said your Excellency why but why
do you send me a picture of my home
I said Abdul you're gonna have to figure
that one out for yourself
but you know what we didn't lose
one soldier in 18 months now think of it
not one soldier was even shot at
they were at Bay
and we were going to get out with pride
and with dignity we're going to take all
of our equipment out I told the generals
I want every screw I won every Bolt
I want every tank I want every plane I
want every helicopter I want everything
out
sir can we leave the hangers you know
those big canvas covered hangers nope
they come out General Sir I think it
would be a lot easier to leave the
equipment behind this was Millie that's
when I realized he's a fool
I said so you mean to tell me General
that if we have a hundred million dollar
airplane sitting there you want to leave
that and you think that's a good thing
leave the airplane leave the helicopters
which they did leave all of this very
expensive we could just fill it up with
a little jet fuel and fly it to Pakistan
or fly at home
uh yes sir I think it would be a good
idea to leave it that's where these
ideas came from can you imagine we left
85 billion dollars worth of equipment
in Afghanistan and I just read a report
the other day that they are about the
second largest seller of arms in the
whole world
we sell more than they do a little bit
but they're the second largest can you
imagine that they're so because they
don't need 700 000 rifles you know we
left behind talking about guns NRA
000 guns and rifles some of them the
finest
in the world some of them even are
people right up here that are so wealthy
I know them they wish they could afford
guns like we left behind for the Taliban
think of it seven hundred thousand
seventy thousand Vehicles many of them
armor plated costing millions of dollars
a piece we left it all behind like a
bunch of fools we're led by stupid
people and let me tell you we've never
been in such danger in our life
I believe it's the most dangerous time
in the history of our country because of
the power of
weaponry and I'm not talking about
rifles now you know
you know the n-word
can't use the n-word two n words you
can't use you can't use it the nuclear
word
the power of these weapons is so and I
would never talk about it I didn't talk
about it and now it's talked about every
single day including by Putin he goes
you know where a great nuclear power
he says that publicly now he never said
that when I was here
because you don't talk about it it's too
destructive you don't talk about it now
they're talking about it all the time
and we have somebody that has no idea
what it is
we've never been in such danger because
of our leadership we've never been in
such danger as we are right now we'll
take Biden's executive order directing
the federal government to Target the
Firearms industry and I will rip it up
and throw it out on day one that'll be
the first thing I do
I'll also get energy started we're
energy independent soon to be energy
dominant I'll get that going quickly
we'll see
you'll see your gasoline and your
heating bills and your cooling bills and
every other Bill you'll see him plummet
and you'll see inflation start to go
away I will eliminate the Biden atf's
ridiculous pistol brace rule which
orders law abiding citizens to register
or Surrender guns with
stabilizing braces right does everybody
like that or should I forget about it
I don't know they wanted me to put that
in I guess some people are happy with it
I don't know
to restore our Second Amendment we will
pass legislation protecting the absolute
right to self-defense with Federal
penalties for prosecutorial abuse like
we saw just
written Texas you saw that
where a man was trying to defend himself
and they want to put him in jail for the
rest of his life and I will ask Congress
to send a bill to my destiny National
concealed carry reciprocity
you want protection
just like your driver's license or your
marriage license your second amendment
must apply across state lines it will
we'll get it done pretty quickly too
the Biden gun control agenda is part and
parcel of the left-wing crusade to
organize government again
law abiding citizens while letting
criminals roam free they're all over the
place
never seen anything like it you're
afraid to walk through one of these
Democrat
cities you go out for a loaf of bread
you end up getting shot
as president I will end the
weaponization of our government
including the ATF the FBI and the doj
they've weaponized
our country
I will dismantle and destroy the Deep
State we made a big progress
and that includes the gun grabbing
bureaucrats who are persecuting gun
owners and manufacturers every single
day you people are getting persecuted by
these left-wing Maniacs no longer will
government Target the left's political
enemies instead we will once again
Target violent criminals I want to go
after the criminals these are mentally
deranged or bad people and we have to go
after them and stop worrying about
somebody that will never hurt anybody
with a gun just wants the gun for
protection or whatever
we will get them behind bars and we will
keep them behind bars they don't even
now in New York we have a district
attorney you can kill somebody
and you don't even have to put a bail
they're out the next hour two hours
it's insane and that's true with many
different cities I don't even know you
talk about April Fool's Day I don't even
know who could think who would think
that this is good murderers Killers
violent
animals are released onto the streets
immediately
they don't even spend time
jail
the first duty of government is to
protect its citizens as an example when
you see these gangs of hundreds of young
usually young people
go and attack an apartment store
Department Store in San Francisco in Los
Angeles and Chicago
and they run in by the hundreds and
they're running out carrying generators
and carrying air conditioners and Big
Stuff big little everything fur coats
non-fur coat everything they're carrying
they empty out the stores
and we our police are incredible but
they're not allowed to do their job they
want to do their job so badly they're
standing there they're shaking they want
to do their job be so easy to do
but they're not allowed to do their job
because of these radical lunatics we
have
thinking they're doing the right thing I
don't even think they do think they're
doing the right thing
the politically incorrect truth that no
one on the left wants to admit is that
violent crime is rarely committed by
illegal gun owners it is it is committed
by a brutal class of hardened repeat
criminals that's who's doing it in San
Francisco
and who would have thought San Francisco
one of the most beautiful cities in the
world in San Francisco murder suspects
have an average of
13.9 Prior arrests and 9.2 felony
arrests think of that one in Portland
shooting suspects have an average of
eight prior arrests and nine criminal
charges
in Washington D.C a place that I'm very
familiar with four years when I saw
tents going up I had them take them down
immediately immediately
you can't do that on this these
incredible parks and these incredible
monuments and they were putting tents up
and I take them down immediately because
you can do that much easier than when
you have hundreds and even thousands you
have to see what's happened to
Washington DC since I've left it's
horrible
beautiful Lawns with tents all over
no respect for our country no respect
for anything
but in Washington DC an estimated 70
percent of all violent crime and there's
a lot of it involving guns is
concentrated among a group of just 500
chronic law Breakers think of that with
most suspects arrested 11 times at least
before being involved in a murder they
ultimately end up in a murder
and then they end up getting
like a year
and sometimes less and sometimes they're
not even prosecuted the only one they
want to prosecute is Donald Trump let's
get Trump let's get that son of a
let's gather
it's unbelievable action these people
are sick you know
a lunatics
this career criminal class cares nothing
about gun laws in Chicago just three
percent of prison inmates who used a gun
bought it at a store so all of the gun
owners in this room a lot of them who's
a gun owner who's a who's a gun owner
first of all
let's let's go differently
is there anybody in the room who doesn't
own a gun please raise raise your hand
if you have the courage
okay and and how many people own gun
stores and sell guns how many people in
the room okay good good good good
business
that's good but let's be very clear the
issue is not too many guns the issue is
too many Thugs hoodlums and Savage
criminals on our street that's really
what the issue
instead of getting these dangerous
Killers into jail
we have radical DA's and attorney
generals prosecutors
all across this country subverting the
law to attack conservative people
and religious people
evangelicals Christians
the very same raging radical left
lunatic attorney general that is coming
after me in New York state is also
Waging War
on the NRA shamefully trying to destroy
this legendary organization that's been
an American institution since 18
71 you know when the NRA endorsed me
in 2016 for the 2016 campaign it was
fairly early
and I do have two sons who are really
good shots I don't know if you know
Eric and Don there's if they were
golfers they'd be scratch
may be better than scratch actually but
they're really good they've been a
member of the NRA for a long time but
and I think maybe that helped but they
endorsed me that was considered one of
the greatest things to do there was like
getting into the Wharton School of
Finance or getting into Harvard or
getting into a great college that was a
great thing and they endorsed me very
early and it was a great honor we did a
great job and they better endorse me
again
Dave
where they're going to have some
explaining to do
they'll have some explaining to them now
I I think we're in pretty good I do
believe we're in pretty good shape but
when you see the polls in a little while
you can understand that we're in pretty
good shape I've never seen such Spirit
as there is right now I've never seen
and part of that sadly is because they
are doing such a horrible job
of running our country which is really
destroying our country
and I think it makes us even more
popular to be honest with you they are
doing such a horrible job what they're
doing is destroying our great country I
want to congratulate you for fighting it
so bravely all of the things that have
been happening to you the racist in
Reverse ran for office on the promise I
will get Trump you ever see the
commercial I will get Trump I'm going to
get them
didn't know anything about me she's
running for office I said who is that
maniac
but I'm watching a campaign and a lot of
people in the race and you know you get
a few people that vote very few people
actually it takes to get in
but she proclaimed I look forward to
going into the office of Attorney
General every single day
suing him and then going home being very
happy
I said oh gee I hope she gets in I hope
she will
but she announced
what is fueling my soul right now is
Trump getting Trump
and she knows nothing about me
so it's not an investigation you're
going through the same thing it's a
persecution
just like her attacks on the NRA and
just like the witch hunts against us by
the Manhattan D.A the Marxist
D.A in Atlanta and the
the guy I have watching this guy's
Central Casting the guy from Washington
special prosecutor they say special
counsel I call it a prosecutors much
better they're looking at the boxes hoax
Biden has
1850 boxes that are unaccounted for he
had many boxes in Chinatown
classified information many boxes they
got them out of there but they got
caught it's called obstruction and they
sent them up to Boston and they sit up
in Boston and then it was revealed that
he got millions of dollars from the
Chinese he got millions of dollars but
he has boxes in Chinatown boxes all over
the place they don't care about that
they only care about Trump
but they're trying to arrest their
political opposition it's really very
much like the old Soviet Union of the
Court Soviet Style with elections and
with the interference they're
interfering with the election that's
what they're doing it's going to be hard
for them to get away with the kind of
corruption they did when they had covet
because kovid made a lot of things bad
for a lot of people but they cheated and
it'll be hard so now I really believe
they're going to prosecutorial way
that's the route where they use
prosecutors to don't forget if you're
not like with me it's sort of
interesting because my
I've gone way up you explained this to
me my numbers have gone way up but other
people
because you know me
you know the truth is the American
public knows me well and they know
that's not my deal but they don't know a
lot of people running for office so if
you have a young good Republican running
for office gets a subpoena
and then they leak it out to the papers
it's impossible for this guy to
go to but the good news is we've gone
way up so we've done something that I
don't believe has ever done before and
we're going to stay there or we're going
to go even higher if we can I'm not sure
you can go higher but we're going to go
even higher if you can because we have
to save our country they're not coming
after me they're coming after you and
I'm just sort of in the way I'm in the
way of these people
and as everybody knows
it's all because we're leading so big in
the polls not only against Republicans
but also against
Joe Biden and if you take a look this
week's morning console poll I led the
field by 33 points with Trump 56 to
Sanctus 23 Pence 5.
I hope you gave Pence a good uh
warm
approval
because now because he is a he is a nice
man if you want to really know the truth
he is he's a good man and I heard it was
very rough it's a big news story you've
made news today I don't know what you
did but you made news today
with with the introduction you gave
and uh
Nikki Haley it's another it's a beauty
she's at four
inhabits at one I don't think Abbott's
gonna run
governor of Texas in a two-way poll of
Florida last week it was Trump 47 and to
Sanctus 32 percent
and there was another poll in Florida
where Trump was at 80.
into Sanctus was at 15 that's a Florida
poll in Texas it's Trump 52 percent the
Sanctus 20.
Pence five Haley four
uh
you know the only way we could lose is
if we go prevent defense do you agree do
you know what that means in football
where they're holding the team to no
score and then they go prevent the last
two minutes and they lose the game
we will never go prevent but you can
take a look on the screen and you'll see
some of these things posted and they're
really big polls in Massachusetts we're
leading by I think like 45 almost 50
points
in New Hampshire we're leading by a lot
in Iowa the farmers can never vote for
me I got
China to pay the farmers
28 billion dollars for the damage that
they caused I said you got to pay
and so you see some of these I just
thought you'd put them up remember in
the old days I used to always announce
polls only if they were good I wouldn't
announce them if they weren't good I had
a bad one I would
but when they were good I
got the opposition crazy
but we're leading Biden Now by a lot
seven points nine points and a ten point
but seven points in the last Rasmussen
poll and I am the one they don't want to
run against that's why they're coming
after me like this if they wanted me to
run they'd say oh no he is the most
perfect human being we've ever seen
instead they put these monsters in there
they put these radical left crazy people
in now if they want to they're the party
of disinformation remember that what
they say you can usually go the opposite
they say oh yeah we want to run against
Trump in the meantime they got 5 000
prosecutors after my ass
we want to run against him so bad we're
gonna run against him
that's the guy we want Trump by the way
please take him out of politics please
get him out as fast as you can
now they're the party of disinformation
or misinformation Nobody Knows the
difference but they're pretty close it's
no wonder that the far-left crazies are
engaging in election interference on a
historic scale nobody outside of this
country nobody has ever seen anything
like what's happening now with the
prosecutors these Marxist prosecutors
who release rapists and murderers while
persecuting conservatives on day one of
my new Administration I will direct the
doj with a very strong leader not like
Barr
not like Bill Barr what a disaster he
was he was a rhino he was afraid of
being impeached please I don't want to
be a so how do you not get
impeached don't do anything
you don't do anything remember they were
going to impeach him and then all of a
sudden
he actually said no he didn't see any
wrongdoing in the election uh
my young son very young so a lot of
people doing a deal every did anybody in
this room can they say they didn't see
any wrong that was the worst
horror show I think one of the greatest
criminal acts ever the election of 2020
but we will turn that around
and it'll be even bigger
you know what it'll be even bigger if
you think about it
it'll be even bigger be much bigger than
having one and we'll be able to do
things
and so bad
in other words they want to show us well
they showed us we have no energy we have
massive crime our military doesn't work
nobody respects Us in the whole world I
mean there's not a leader that respects
our leader
we will show them
through this horrible four years that
we're going through the problem is we
can't take any more of it because we're
not going to have a country left
we will show them that we can do things
and we'll be able to do things on crime
and other elements of society will be
able to do things that you probably
wouldn't have been able to do if you
just carried it forward so I think it's
actually much bigger this could be much
bigger than if we went the more
traditional route
I will direct the doj to investigate
every radical D.A and attorney general
an American for their illegal race and
reverse based enforcement of the law
I will then appoint a team of warrior
U.S attorneys and I know
I know some great ones including from
this area
who will be the polar opposite of
the Sorrows District Attorneys these
guys I mean what they're thinking who
can believe I mean they're not stupid
people they're not stupid people there's
two things they're either stupid
or they hate our country and I don't
think they're stupid because anybody
that can cheat so well in election
they're not stupid
that means they hate our country and I
believe they hate our country they will
be the 100 most ferocious crime fighters
in American history and I will task them
with demolishing every gang Street crew
and criminal Network they can find piece
by piece until Public Safety is fully
restored and that means in democrat-run
cities
and at the top of the list is Washington
DC itself which is absolutely plagued by
numbers and crime that nobody's ever
seen before we've never seen anything
like what's happening in Washington D.C
can you imagine these foreign leaders
coming over
from countries and they're looking at
this filth and squalor
and crime
in our capital
and I think we have to take it over we
have to take over management of our
Capital because the people that are
running including the mayor who did
nothing about January 6 he was the one
no we don't need anybody we don't need
any help along with crazy Nancy Pelosi
they did nothing they did absolutely
nothing they were supposed to they were
a judge of it
but all of our democrat-run cities are
being absolutely ruined and destroyed as
we sit here and talk they're being
ruined I will order the ATF to stop
bullying gun store owners and wanting to
shut them down for paperwork areas and
instead go after drug dealers human
traffickers and criminal cartels which
is what they should be going after
under Biden other countries are emptying
out their prisons insane asylums and
mental institutions and sending them
right here to the USA can you imagine
prisons and mental institutions are
being emptied out I read a story not
long ago where a man who takes care of a
large segment of people in a mental
institution in a South American country
a doctor sounded like a great man
actually
he said he no longer has anything to do
he used to work 24-hour days he said all
of our patients have been released into
the United States of America
and this is what we have this is what
we've allowed to happen and we can't
allow this to happen because we will not
have a country any longer we can't allow
it to happen under my leadership we will
quickly restore the most secure Border
in U.S history we had the strongest
Border in history and now we have I
think the worst Border in the history of
the world because no country even a
third world country would allow
what's happening right now to us to
happen to them
the first reconciliation bill I signed
for a massive increase in Border Patrol
these border patrol Brandon Judd and all
of his people they're incredible the job
they do Tom Holmen as a man that knows
it do you see him on television I call
him Central Casting but these two guys
and all of the people that work with him
this is so good they want to do their
job
it's going to be a colossal increase in
creasing the number of ice and border
patrol deportation offices following the
Eisenhower model I don't know if you
know Dwight Eisenhower was very tough on
the subject we will use all necessary
State local Federal and Military
resources to carry out the largest
domestic deportation operation in
American history
and I will ask every state and federal
agency to identify every known or
suspected gang member in America and
every one of them that is here legally
we will pick them up and we will send
them back to the country from which they
came
as we restore safety to our streets
we have no choice
as we restore safety to our streets we
must also restore it to our schools
hardening places of learning we have to
harden our assets to protect our
children against threats of any kind
last month our hearts were Shattered by
news of the Monstrous attack on a
Christian Elementary School in Nashville
that claimed the lives of three adults
and three precious children today we
wrap those beautiful families in our
love and we lift them up in our prayers
we also salute the law enforcement
Heroes who ran into danger and took out
that killer
speed and skill that made us all very
very proud
that made us all very very proud
it's a scandal and a tragedy
that year after year Democrats in
Washington continue to hold Common Sense
school safety measures Hostage to their
radical gun control agenda which in
virtually all cases would do nothing to
prevent attacks by demented and
Disturbed individuals of which we have
many and many are coming into our
country but we're getting them out our
country has been chock full of guns for
centuries and there was no talk of
massacres of school children until
around the year 2000 that's when it
really started they started talking
about it this is not a gun problem this
is a mental health problem this is a
social problem this is a cultural
problem this is a spiritual problem
each and every one of these heinous
attacks depend on the same cold-blooded
calculation that the evil monster will
have a window of time to act out their
demonic fantasy unchallenged they want
to be unchallenged they don't want
challenged the only way to stop these
Wicked axes to ensure that any sicko who
would shoot up a school knows that
within seconds not minutes they will
face
certain death they have to know that
and they won't be doing it
for this reason I will ask Congress to
repeal totally ineffective legislation
that makes it harder to protect our
schools and easier for criminals to face
absolutely no opposition when they go in
I will also create a new tax credit to
reimburse Any teacher for the full cost
of a concealed carry firearm and
training from highly qualified experts
who's better who's better
if even five percent of teachers people
that are skilled with arms we want that
five percent
were voluntarily armed and trained to
stop active Shooters we would achieve
effective deterrence and the problem
would cease to exist and that would be a
lot of people but these are all people
that are trained and talented with
firearms for about 12 billion dollars we
could fund armed security guards at the
entrance every school in America and
also arm every willing teacher we want
to arm some of these teachers they have
to go through
rigorous or some people say vigorous I
like vigorous better I don't like rigors
they have to go through vigorous
training but they were already there
and they'll do better than anybody you
could put in and they love our children
they really love our children and we can
send 120 billion dollars to Ukraine then
we can afford one tenth of that amount
to protect American children in American
schools
we also need to drastically change our
approach to mental health upon my
inauguration I will direct the FDA to
convene and it's so it's going to happen
quickly to convene an independent
outside panel
to investigate whether transgender
hormone treatments and ideology increase
the risk of extreme depression
aggression and even violence I think
most of us already know the answer don't
we furthermore we have to look at
whether common
psychiatric drugs as well as genetically
engineered cannabis and other narcotics
are causing psychotic breaks a lot of
problems we're having problems that
we've never seen before and people sort
of think they understand why we must
also be much better at detecting warning
signs of evil disturbed young men like
the one who murdered colleagues in
Louisville we cannot rest until we get
to the bottom of all of the sickness
that we're seeing in our country I will
fight
to restore our safety and I will also
fight to reclaim our freedom we're going
to have freedom in our country we're
going to be able to walk down the street
and buy a loaf of bread and come back
and not be shot
to defend our Constitution and the rule
of law I will give
you my word today that I will appoint
Rock Solid constitutional conservatives
to crush the Communists from
our federal bench they are communists
many of them
we did a great job
we set a record
but there's more to go before election
day 2024 I will Once Again release the
full list of names from which I select
my appointments to the United States
Supreme Court so everyone can see who
I'm thinking about putting there I did
that last time and a lot of people said
it made a big difference
it will be an also a roster of young
Fearless originalists in the mold of
Justin Anton and Scalia great man
and a great Lion of American Liberty
Justice Clarence Thomas by the way
they're after him did you see they're
after him now
they're after Clarence now
but he can take care of himself very
well at the same time conservatives can
no longer sit by and wait for the courts
to save America our country is being
plundered and ransacked by radical left
barbarians who are trying to burn down
every right and every Liberty that we
hold so dear the next time we have power
Congress has to step up and stop this
Marxist revolution in its tracks we have
a Marxist Revolution going on and I
think you're starting to see it I think
you're starting to see it and we have to
stop it fast
this is what we must do to save our
country
with your Vote or with a republican
house and a Republican Senate and we
have a really good chance at both I will
lead the great Rebirth of American
Freedom we will build a future where
we're free of crime and free of violence
and Free From Fear
this fear
where we are free from dependence on
foreign countries we're so dependent on
so many foreign countries in particular
China
where we are free from the shackles of
an unelected deep state from corrupt
intelligence agencies free from War free
from poverty
free to speak our minds and last but
certainly not least free to keep and
bear arms
I have to State the USA is a mess
our economy is crashing
inflation is out of control
Russia has joined with China unthinkable
Saudi Arabia great people
have joined with Iran
China Russia Iran North Korea have
formed together as a menacing and
destructive coalition
our currency is crashing and will soon
no longer be the world standard
which will be our greatest defeat in 200
years and was Unthinkable just a few
years ago Unthinkable that that could
happen but it's happening before your
very eyes
and we won't let it happen with me
not even a chance just like Russia would
have never invaded Ukraine and China
would not be
having even a thought of raiding Taiwan
you didn't hear about these things when
I was president
if you took the five worst Presidents in
the history of the United States
and added them up they would not have
done near the destruction to our country
as Joe Biden and the Biden
Administration have done
we are a failing Nation
we are a nation in Decline
and now these radical left lunatics want
to interfere with our elections by using
law enforcement and we can't let that
happen
but with all of this being said
and with a very dark cloud hanging over
our country
I have no doubt
that we will together as a group make
America great again I have no doubt
thank you thank you very much God bless
you all God bless you
live
[Music]
behind the man